how do you feel mr trump
never before has a former u.s president
been suspected of violating the
espionage act according to the warrant
authorizing the fbi search of trump's
estate trump may have kept documents
that could endanger national security
and may have destroyed or concealed
presidential records this week federal
agents removed 11 sets of classified
documents from mar-a-lago four sets were
labeled top secret and reportedly may
contain information about nuclear
weapons many lesser people
have gotten prosecuted for doing a small
fraction
of what it appears that donald trump has
done which has
taken the single most highly classified
documents the united states government
has
has taken them have taken them to his
home other seized documents relate to
french president emmanuel macron and to
trump's pardoning of his close associate
roger stone trump says he declassified
all materials he and aides took from the
white house he and republican supporters
called the investigation a political
witch hunt
president donald trump is joe biden's
most likeliest political opponent in
2024 and this is less than 100 days from
critical midterm elections the fbi rate
of president trump is a complete abuse
and overreach of its authority the
department of justice says it and the
fbi are acting independently
biden has remained silent and while some
democrats say this is trump getting his
due others urge caution i think for the
most part people want to see the process
play out i agree with that i don't want
to interfere with what law enforcement
is doing but i think it would be wrong
to take the position because this person
is a former president that we should
look the other way when there could be
violations of the law the justice
department must now decide whether to
charge trump with a crime which would be
a first in american history and the
decision would be further complicated if
trump announces he's running for
president again
because charging a political candidate
could be seen as election interference
heidi joe castro al jazeera washington